[Applaudissements]
ma question s'adresse à madame la
Première ministre en un mois les
atteintes à la laïcité ont doublé dans
les établissements scolaires elle
concerne dans la majorité des cas le
port de tenue et de signes religieux
face à cette réalité il y a deux
attitudes possibles ce borné a des
réponses techniques alors que clairement
une circulaire ne suffira pas ou
affronter cette offensive politique qui
est à l'oeuvre sur les réseaux sociaux
et qui conduit les adolescents à
contester la primauté de nos principes
républicains il faut dire ce que l'on
voit surtout il faut toujours ce qui est
plus difficile des epégi voir ce que
l'on voit aujourd'hui comment 1989 avec
l'affaire des trois collégiennes voilées
de Creil la situation impose une parole
politique forte il avait fallu attendre
Jacques Chirac en 2004 pour qu'une loi
se dresse et protège l'école de
l'islamisme aujourd'hui à nouveau cette
idéologie relance son offensive en
utilisant le vêtement comme un étendard
et des adolescents comme des portes
drapeau les enseignants comme les élèves
et leurs parents ont besoin d'un
discours politique tenu au plus haut
niveau madame même la première ministre
je m'adresse à vous parce que vous avez
dédié votre nomination à Matignon aux
petites filles en leur disant d'aller au
bout de leurs rêves vous êtes au
rendez-vous de la responsabilité madame
la Première ministre êtes-vous prête à
dire qu'en France comment en Iran ou en
Afghanistan tout vêtement qui affiche la
soumission des filles n'a pas sa place à
l'école